hi my name is eat I said I work for
Wolfram research and my talk is called
version 12 enhancements for the
pre-college classroom in which I'll be
talking about enhancements for both
pre-college and college level math
classes that have been made in
functionality usability and
documentation for version 12
okay well welcome everyone I'll be
talking about version 12 enhancements
for the pre-college and college
classroom and when I say version 12 I
mean after eleven point oh so some of
these things were in 11.1 somewhere in
11.2 some of these things are new in 12
and some things are coming in 12:1 okay
so as as the vendor mentioned in the
previous talk we have these new equation
manipulation functions this I believe
was new in 11.3 add sides subtract sides
multiply sides divide sides and for
completeness we also have this apply
sides which is a little bit different
because it's if to actually make it like
the others would be a much much more
difficult proposition so and at the
simplest use add sides and multiply
sides they're all pretty much the same
at sites adds the same thing to both
sides of an equation or if you want to
combine two equations you can give two
equations and in this case subtract them
now you're not limited to two sided
equations you can have three sided
equations and it'll you know then then
they need to if you're do if you have
two equations they need to be the same
length because otherwise it's like well
what am I supposed to how am I supposed
to make them match but and these
functions are mathematically aware so in
this case so both subtract sides and
divide sides have a one argument form
which the multiply sides and add sides
don't have which is move everything to
the left hand side and so but it knows
that you can't divide by zero so the
result is a over B equals one if B is
not equal to zero and otherwise that you
know it has to stay equals B but these
functions don't just know about
equations
I was worried this might happen which is
fortunately I have this version which
should be here ah so the short answer is
we don't know but I think I think it's
trying to dynamically resize things to
the screen and it's getting stuck in
that computation so this is a simpler
style sheet that doesn't try to be so
clever and so it also doesn't have this
bug okay and so right so we can support
inequalities and do I need to make this
view yet this is tiny on that screen so
that's the downside of the
less-intelligent
that looks like a good size if people
want me to make it bigger just tell me
so right so you can do inequalities you
can combine multiple types of in a
relation so here we're combining
inequality and then inequality and if
you multiply an inequality by something
symbolic as opposed to something
concrete it'll tell you well the result
depends on the sign of the thing you
multiplied by then we have apply sides
which allows you to apply arbitrary
functions to you know both sides of an
equation or inequality but this one is a
purely sort of structural operation so
for example if I apply sine to both
sides of an inequality well depending on
the value of the point that may or may
not still be a true result as shown here
and that's just because for an arbitrary
function deriving the conditions it's
just not what is the purpose of this
function okay so that's some very basic
algebra improvements we've made a lot of
limits improvements to limit so those of
you who are longtime users may know that
limit used to give a one-sided limit by
default now it gives a two-sided limit
and so this limit doesn't exist you can
ask for limits in other directions so
limit from above to live it from below
limit as you approach into complex plane
and the result is complex infinity we
also have new easy to remember direct
value for Direction you might recall you
had to guess whether plus-one meant from
above or from below and get it wrong at
least half the time so now we have from
above and it gives you the limit from
above and can you guess what its friend
is well I deliberately only typed half
of it in to show you that it shows
little it's a little small there but you
see that a bunch of completions came up
from above from below complex says reals
is the default that means both sided you
can also use the string two-sided but we
prefer reals and so you know we're
giving you better help we're giving you
easier to remember names and when you're
try to type them in we're giving you
better help about what you can type in
anyway and direction of oh those are
that's a new feature where those are
links to the documentation so I will
just make that reappear very quick lips
very quickly so the you you may not be
able to see but there it's a little book
icon next to them and so that's saying
you're looking for direction for values
for direction and you're inside of limit
and I have documentation from pages for
both of these symbols so go straight to
the help page for those functions no no
I disagree you can only have you can
only have so many values certainly in in
the short list like that you don't want
too many and I think from above and from
below are pretty clear
I mean we could maybe understand them
why well that's from above okay okay
well then maybe we should add those as
synonyms to the to the table that's okay
that all right well we decided that from
above and from below was more common in
English we had a fair discussion of this
but that's it thank you
whoa yeah right okay Adam you're a post
speaker why didn't you tell us this all
right right limits of sequences so this
is so sometimes if you you have the same
expression but depending on whether
you're thinking of it as a function over
the reals or a function over the
integers you get a different value for
the limit so here's sine of X pi and
sine of n PI and one doesn't have a
limit as you go to infinity the other
zero because it's really a constant
sequence and similarly here's -1 to the
2x and minus 1 to the 2n and so we have
a new special function discrete limit
which is for computing limits of
sequences and it can be at either
positive or negative infinity I've just
done positive infinity here and not so
much for your first two years of college
but we also have limbs it lemon fin limb
soup so 4 minus 1 to the N right it's 1
n minus 1 and similarly for sine of n PI
sorry sine of X pi which doesn't have a
limit but obviously has a limb soup and
and since I'm a little bit behind where
I want to be I'll just go go through
this very quickly but we also support
now true multi-dimensional limits so I'm
taking the limit of this function as we
approach the point zero zero from all
directions you can try so this notation
point goes to point or variables goes to
point means approach in all directions
this you know one variable go list of
variable goes to point variable goes to
POI means take them in sequence so limit
as X goes to 0 then limit as X goes to Y
you get zero limit as Y goes to zero
then X goes to zero you get a different
value if you try to approach along the
line x equals y you get the third value
and so you know we have one of these
very singular points and there is no
limit and using direction-- can be not
just a single value but a list of values
and so you can limit to 1/2 planes or
quadrants right if you say both side
there's an X but from above and Y etc
you can limit half planes quadrants etc
so documentation was rewritten to match
the functionality obviously the details
section has intuition building in
illustrations and here are some notable
examples so geometric limits is so we
compute here and let me make this bigger
so you might actually be able to see it
right so we compute the the the
perimeter of a regular polygon we take
the limit of that as n goes to infinity
we get 2pi r we compute the area of the
regular polygon again take the limit and
here we have a nice illustration of
what's happening limits assuming so
here's another manipulate basically
you know as you zoom in one function has
a limit as as you go to zero the other
is going crazy so no limit and sort of a
very handy right we have sort of
application examples which are you know
sort of inspired by things calculus
students might have so for example we
have a function we want to find its
domain okay it's not defined at x equals
0 we take the limit as X goes to 0 so
there's no limit however we have limits
above and below and so there's a jump
discontinuity and right we have an
example with a removable disk in
discontinuity etc and just since I
mentioned them here's the new details
and options so we show how to type this
in so now we have a limit operator that
you can use too so it looks more like
your classroom notation we have these
illustrations trying to explain what are
you know what's going on and so maybe we
need to expand this table to have from
the left and from the right an actual
illustration to explain what when you
give it a numerical value what that
numerical value means etcetera okay so
that's what I wanted to tell you about
the limit
differentiation and integration so we've
added some features you wouldn't think
that at this point we would have a lot
to add to D but we found a couple so we
have symbolic order derivatives so if
you take the F ask for the nth
derivative of X its X if and as a 0 1 if
n is 1 and 0 if it's any higher
derivative and you might think the N
equals 0 case is a little bit redundant
but it's really not because if you say
have a product and you need to take the
nth order derivative of each side then
you know you need that base case in
order for your resulting formula to be
correct
or the aunt derivative of sine gives you
this formula you take a table for
different values of N and you see your
nice cycle of for for derivatives of
sine we also have simpler results for
certain important special functions
so here's Bessel J you get two terms
with a simple polynomial in front of the
two bezels and this is for the third
order result this is as opposed to a sum
of eight so in the old result you'd have
2 to the N different bezel functions
running around that you'd have to sort
of collect and simplify and I just want
to point out that we're not just simply
applying the the nth order result we
have a special technique for so called
holonomic functions to compute nice
formulas directly because we would have
n terms if we had just applied and as
opposed to two terms so we've
strengthened indefinite integration by
popular demand we now have constants of
integration so if you can say generated
parameters goes to C and you know for
your indefinite integral get X cubed
over 3 plus C but of course constants of
integration sometimes aren't so constant
so if you take 2 to 2 integrals that in
different variables then you have an
arbitrary function in one variable and
an arbitrary function and the other
variable because when you then take the
the mixed partial those will both
disappear and you get back to the
function you started with and we for
completeness extended this to the
discrete integral also known as some and
also product whoops a so difference
Delta is the derivative for some
discrete ratio is the derivative for
product and notice how constants are
generally flowing to the right for
additive ones and to the left for
multiplicative ones
we had a little issue in traditional
form where the rules for trying to make
nice polynomials interfered with that
that is fixed in 12:1 so they'll be at
the end again also in traditional form
new integration rules so we've added
some new integration rules for
indefinite integrals these are most
noticeable and integrals with parameters
in them because integral and agreat was
already very strong in this and there's
something called the Ruby benchmark out
there you might be familiar with we can
do essentially all the integrals on the
Ruby benchmark now so here's an example
I actually managed to find of an
integral without parameters that we can
now do but a more typical case of the
kind of integral that you can now do
notice I have here an M to the power M
it's hard to come up with a closed
formula for that you can but you need
hyper geometric functions so for any
concrete M integrate to do this that's
right it's just a simple rational
function but for arbitrary m we can now
do that to you this was really a
challenge coming up with a sort of calc
2 or a sort of integral that is now
simpler because of our new rules yes
no I'm there yeah there might be a
branch cut somewhere in there that that
it is being avoided but I'd have to
think about it
so I mean you will find so a lot of
times when you so a lot of the ones that
we can do you are have fractional powers
and it's precisely because we can now do
them because we have a formula that
avoids the branch cut so right so here's
at least one that an integral that you
might think a cockatoo student might
type in and you know there's a result
you know they should have they're
supposed to know what an arctangent they
may claim not to but they should and so
you notice that one came back pretty
instantly this one was not so instant
and we have some elliptic F's and
elliptic pies and whatnot so this is
definitely a nicer simpler result for
students and like limit we've rewritten
the documentation and so we have many
more examples again and many inspired by
calculus text so I will just show you a
couple of my favorites so l'hopital's
rule right so I guess I should point out
and again it made it small so let me
write so if you look at just our
sections here we have rates of change
and plus it functions optimization and
l'hopital's rule so we have you know a
couple of functions the limit are both
zero we can you know we can carefully
check that the conditions for
l'hopital's rule that it's not zero in
some neighborhood of the point of the
punctured neighborhood is satisfied
and the so f Prime and G prime are
continuous and G prime is not equal zero
so it's either you know we don't even
really need to take the limit we can
just compute F prime over G F prime of
zero over G prime of zero and we have
this pretty illustration of it this
[Music]
regions of revolution so this is on
integrate so we have you know arc length
volume regions of revolution area
between curves so here's you know pretty
straightforward one we we have something
rotated around the x-axis we can just
you know we set up the integral and we
have a nice plot of you know to
visualize the surface fundamental
theorem of calculus so I won't go
through this in detail but I will sort
of jump to the punchline of this example
that I have an F I defined G and here
I'm plotting G and F and sort of the
difference quotient for G based at a
particular point and F and you can write
you can move X around and you can shrink
H and sort of show intuitively the
fundamental theorem of calculus and so
the sum I mean obviously this is a
pretty complicated example but my point
is these are not just for the students
if you want to have a nice manipulate to
show in class instructors can steal
these examples and and make use of them
and I'll just show you one of these
three examples oh right so II well I
guess I should show you two so this one
isn't an example this is the notes we've
sort of updated them to make clear sort
of what it means how you can type them
in using sort of a partial derivative
operator and sort of the different
syntaxes but also we sort of have
examples of for example how to type in a
template
and and you know fill it in in order to
type in an indefinite integral which
leads naturally to my next slide user
interface enhancements so implicit multi
so we've long had this thing where you
have when you type in two numbers in a
row there's a little gray time sign so
you know you're multiplying that you
have two times three and not
twenty-three there but we've generalized
this to many more expressions so if you
have just arbitrary functions F and G
multiplied it'll show you the that and
for example if you're inside of a
function and you have you forgot the
semicolon then having the little x at
the end of the of the line - now oh i
mean i'm multiplying by the next line is
really useful on the other hand we don't
want it in between you know - and sine
and cosine so that's in 12 already you
know this intelligent omission in 12 1
were improving the curation without
giving the front and access to the
kernels list of mathematical functions
so you know we should that should be
better
we don't have capacity for that yet that
has been requested but it's it's it's
it's not there yet and then so I will
just show you one of these two examples
but you've always been able to well for
long you've been able to get completions
for letters for special characters you
but when you type in escape and start
putting in its shortcut but now we also
have completions for what we call input
aliases which are sort of more more
generic things so for example we see
here del del dot del X del to give you
little templates for a you know for a
gradient for a curl or for a laplacian
and so that's a nice usability
enhancement and syntax coloring we have
we've just as d and integrate and solved
now you have long sort of colored
they're variables we've now made sure
that find maximum and lots of other
related functions also do this okay I
don't have really time to go into this
but and I guess there will be a whole
talk about special functions
so I'll just say we've sort of reviewed
and updated 252 math functions the the
discrete math team which is a slightly
separate team from us is looking at a
hundred additional pages which are more
number theory or discrete math type
functions and this is an ongoing process
insuring sort of consistent presentation
among different function groups so all
the trig functions have you know the
same set of examples or possible issues
etc and which of these do I have time
for so I will just mention we now have
things like positive reals and negative
reals which format nicely
with little tooltips and we have input
shortcuts we have some formatting tweaks
like conditional expression that the
vendor mentioned and there was a
separate talk on sort of Euclidean
geometry earlier so I recommend you you
if you didn't go to it you can watch the
video or download the slides from the
path of all web site
so in conclusion we've expanded
capability usability and documentation
with a view towards making Mathematica
better for use in the classroom we're
still working on more and feel free to
get in touch and any last minute quick
questions before I hand things off to Ed
them